for some comedians Saturday Night Live
represents the biggest thing they'll
ever do in show business for whatever
reason their success on late-night
comedy TV never quite transferred other
aspects of the entertainment industry
and they never quite caught that big
Hollywood break while appearing on
Saturday Night Live Jan hooks seem to do
absolutely everything required of a
future comedy superstar her inspired
Betty Davis and personation is legendary
in its own right she played several
recurring characters that instantly
endeared her to audiences including her
iconic portrayal of candy Sweeney of The
Sweeney sisters nightclub act after
leaving SNL in 1991 Jan hooks never
quite landed a role that showcased her
immense talents she briefly joined the
cast of designing women that same year
replacing gene smarts
unfortunately that show was on its last
legs and it simply couldn't survive such
enormous cast changes designing women
ultimately went off the air in 1993 she
had funny recurring roles on 3rd Rock
from the Sun and 30 rock and she
memorably voiced appu's wife
Manjula on The Simpsons still hooks
didn't find nearly as many projects as
she deserved
when hooks unexpectedly passed away in
2014 at the age of 57 several SNL
legends paid homage to the comedian
former cast mate Kevin Nealon tweeted my
girlfriend in the 80s and my friend
forever Janus God you were talented too
soon and too sad producer Lorne Michaels
let go of most of the long-standing SNL
cast members in 1995 bringing in a new
slate of performers that included Will
Ferrell Molly Shannon and Darrell
Hammond on a show that often includes
impersonations of celebrities and
political figures it's important for SNL
to always have a man of a thousand
voices in the mix from 1995 to 2009
Hammond was that man a remarkably
skilled in freshness he's probably the
best mimic the show has ever seen he
took a nuanced realistic approach
consistently turning in remarkable
impersonations of Bill Clinton Donald
Trump and Sean Connery I'll take the
fact that Hammond disappeared so
thoroughly into his characters may go
some way in explaining why he never
quite got the attention he deserved even
after 14 years in the cast he scored a
few bit parts in movies like scary movie
3 and landed recurring roles on a few TV
shows like damages but he's never been
cast in any particularly monumental
roles in 2014 Hammond rejoined the SNL
family assets announcer taking over for
the deceased Don Pardo any SNL highlight
reel that covers the early 80s tends to
focus on Eddie Murphy's work in classic
sketches like mr. Robinson's
neighborhood the cast mate Joe Piscopo
was almost as big of a star a fact
that's often obscured by Murphy's
tremendous post SNL success Piscopo
performed a wide range of well-done
impressions on SNL including Ronald
Reagan Richard Nixon and most famously
Frank Sinatra in fact Murphy and Piscopo
teamed up for a classic sketch parodying
the 1982 song evany and ivory with
Murphy playing Stevie Wonder Piscopo
playing Sinatra what's his name the one
that looks like a broad his capella
Murphy appeared on screen together a lot
in fact
Piscopo played pokey to Murphy's Gumby
but then in 1984 Piscopo left SNL that
same year he starred in Johnny
dangerously a send-up of 1930s gangster
movies he couldn't grab me Johnny
my mother grabbed me once once this capo
was well-suited to playing tough guys
like Danny vermin but the film flopped
at the box office in fact it was
trounced on its opening weekend by Eddie
Murphy's Beverly Hills Cop Fisk opposed
career turned into a string of small
roles and TV shows
along with a few stand-up specials for
cable TV an extreme interest in
bodybuilding and in 2017
floating plans to run for governor of
New Jersey as we mentioned earlier SNL
cleaned house in the fall of 1995
bringing in a bunch of new performers to
inject some energy into the aging comedy
institution Cheri Oteri a vet
Trin of the LOS angeles-based
Groundlings comedy troupe was among them
she brought that live theatre dynamic to
television with a collection of truly
wild and zany characters you can take
your coat off if you like it's from the
Burlington Coat Factory who can forget
her psychotically enthusiastic spartan
cheerleader Ariana what about that
no-nonsense Nadine
Oh Terry was also celebrated for her
brilliantly silly impersonations of
Barbara Walters and Debbie Reynolds she
often appeared and sketches opposite
formidable co-stars like Will Ferrell
and Molly Shannon photo Terry always
held her own to say the least
she was without a doubt one of SNL's
brightest stars until she left the show
in 2000 later that year she landed the
major role of Gail hailstorm in the hit
screen send up scary movie she went on
to star in the unfortunate Dumb and
Dumber prequel dumb and Dumberer When
Harry Met Lloyd since then she's taken
on several guest starring gigs and voice
roles frankly she deserves better
plenty of SNL stars go big and broad to
get a reaction from the audience but
Nora done completely disappeared into
her roles much like a film actress
between 1985 and 1990 done stepped into
several classic sketches and she was
never anything less than hilarious you
might remember her ridiculous turn as
leona helmsley right away you'll notice
the little things things like real
skeletons or how about Babette the ever
maudlin French prostitute
[Music]
wo and but Dunn's most famous SNL
contribution may have been controversy
she publicly boycotted the
second-to-last episode of the 1989-90
season hosted by comedian Andrew Dice
Clay because she found his material
homophobic abusive to women in a 1990
interview with Larry King Clay basically
accused her of doing it all for
publicity I mean you know examples nor
were done more likely she was simply
offended by his act since leaving the
show Don has landed a lot of character
driven work making appearances in shows
like Grace and Frankie and it's always
sunny in philadelphia but with such
boundless talent she deserves a few plum
rolls that she can really sink her teeth
into Ellen cleghorne was a vital part of
the Saturday Night Live cast of the
early 90s playing a long line of
memorable characters like Queen Shaniqua
Kwan's is the Swahili word and it means
Santa don't come to mouth cleghorne left
the show of her own volition in 1995
when the WB gave the comic performer her
very own sitcom called cleghorne but it
was cancelled after just one season as
far as film work is concerned Adam
Sandler did cast her in a supporting
role in grown-ups - still she's got a
lot going on after going back to school
and earning a PhD in performance studies
at New York University's Tisch School of
the Arts you should now refer to her as
dr. Ellen cleghorne
so there Garrett Morris made television
history in 1975 is one of the original
Saturday Night Live cast members or as
the group of relative unknowns was
collectively known the
not-ready-for-prime-time players
starring on the envelope-pushing series
brought fame and fortune to almost
everyone in the original cast so why not
Garrett Morris
during SNL's early years Mora stood out
for his wild and crazy' characters there
was of course the Weekend Update
translator for the hard-of-hearing a bit
that never gets old
and fun facts
Morris became the first actor to ever
play ant-man on screen indeed he
portrays the character in the SNL sketch
called superhero party well that
certainly explains Morris's cameo and
ant-man doesn't it while former
castmates like Bill Murray and Dan
Aykroyd dominated film comedy in the
eighties Morris found the occasional
role and appeared in some rather
middling fair he had a brief cameo in
the comedy how to beat the high cost of
living which co-starred fellow SNL alum
Jane Curtin at the age of 74 he was cast
as diner cashier Earl on the
long-running two Broke Girls so now
there's that Paul Brittain was 33 when
he joined Saturday Night Live in 2010 he
quickly made a name for himself thanks
to some oddball and totally original
characters why here comes Lord Cecil
Wyndemere an immature old timey
aristocrat who dances around the
harpsichord music clearly possesses a
pronounced sweet tooth what don't let
his opulent finals fool you he's not so
different from you and I and anyone
remember this character we should import
Goren funkyboy Bogdan I go to your sonic
restaurant i order a plate of dough
bouzouki they tell me the washroom is
that way during the 2011-12 season SNL's
Lorne Michaels put Britain on a half
season contract and opted not to renew
it making for an abrupt midseason
disappearance since then Britain has
racked up scarcely more than a dozen
credits all of them small character
parts probably his most prominent work
came in killing Gunther an indie comedy
written and directed by his old SNL pal
Taran Killam Jerry miner has been a part
of numerous innovative comedy projects
and worked with plenty of comic
visionaries both before and after his
two short tenure on SNL which only
lasted through the 2000-2001 season
Hey Hey what is it mister Tarkanian oh
thank you that's exactly the response
I'm looking for however such comedy's
leaning more towards the cult classic
column than Smash Hits prior to SNL
minor co-starred on David Cross and Bob
Odenkirk edgy and influential sketch
comedy series mr. show he was also a
correspondent on The Daily Show public
briefly following SNL minor starred on
the Comedy Central debate parody
cross-balls and had a recurring role as
officer Carter on the rest of
development he also played an
overburdened dad on ABC's short-lived
carpoolers most recently minor popped up
on unbreakable kimmy schmitt as an inept
prosecutor named Chris who just might be
based on Oh Jay Simpson prosecutor
Christopher Darden in 1982 Eddie Murphy
hosted SNL while still in the cast
filling in for his sick 48 hours co-star
Nick Nolte he also changed the show's
famous cold-open Proclamation changing
it to live from New York it's the Eddie
Murphy show and SNL in the early 80s was
indeed the Eddie Murphy show in fact the
comedy dynamo the solid work of many
other cast members including Tim
kazarinski here he's interviewing
Richard Nixon played by Joe Piscopo
beneath several pounds of makeup how
does it feel to be the most vilified man
in the country
Ross sensational I look after leaving
SNL in 1984 Qasr in ski hit Hollywood
which in the mid-80s needed guys like
him to play nerds and dweebs
case in point he portrayed Carl sweet
Chuck in three police academy sequels
also an SNL writer Qasr in ski went on
to write scripts for movies in TV
co-writing the 1986 romantic dramedy
about last night the 1988 film for keeps
and writing an episode of according to
Jim Lauren Kyte winger was a force to be
reckoned with on the stand-up comedy
circuit in the 90s and her
self-deprecating wit instantly won her
over with audiences she eventually
landed on Saturday Night Live as a
double threat working as both a writer
and a performer during the 1994-1995
season indeed the SNL cast was so
overstuffed she reportedly struggled to
get her material and her face on the air
after her brief stint with late-night
comedy
kite linger returned to stand-up and
launched a bunch of small film and TV
roles in 2006 she emerged with gigs on
two prominent shows HBO's lucky Louie
and I have seized the minor
accomplishments of Jackie Woodman tight
linker created the latter a semi
autobiographical tale of a
self-destructed struggling screenwriter
Kai Langer still acts on occasion he or
she is in a recent episode of pen15 we
don't have much time before the show but
as you know something of Heather's was
stolen a song these days she's mainly
focusing her attention elsewhere she's a
successful writer and producer who's
worked on Will & Grace a show she's also
appeared in on occasion surely all these
accomplishments take some of the sting
out of her less than legendary SNL stent
maybe marriages in my future
you do yeah check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]